what's going on reject nice and it's
Greg out but here is John Humphrey over
here I just got so nervous I'm so bad at
doing accents time oh yeah that was
great what I did all right guys it was
very never up you might know from
Collider she also has her own solo
channel which is great I've seen a few
of her video she spent at the con she
doesn't need those guys how I can i you
know provide I need well I needed those
guys to get to be able to be really
going on thing we're gonna watch this
trailer today that was sent over to us
and I was like why would I watch this
and then I saw that the dislike ratio
was way higher than the like ratio boy
sounds like I got a lot area I gotta
check this out it's an animated movie
called duck-duck-goose
I really hope this is like a sci-fi
based around the game you know what's
really funny is I got a press release
for this trailer in my inbox and
normally I'm just like trash trash trash
rest and I stop because I'm like what
the heck is doc know there's a whole
mythology to begin never knew about
until now there you go I wouldn't
supposed to sit back for your Lombok
because my camera ready position for
sounds over here yes what is migrated to
William come on yeah
if they have a zoo - I'll give you one
more chance I guarantee you my arugula
is a kid with kids is community
hero who Saturday this is a family
friendly communities you enough sama
attention yeah so what's the problem
do we have to migrate in a v-formation
you
ah those your teeth sir Larry and other
gland we got some pregnancy mouthwash
can you help us or not I would say
Amador no bond look up now okay if he
does ever closer no chance and they
don't let us have no idea what you're
doing me we're all creatures
brother indestructible they go hey
another baby figure to make a good
cookie no water does bunch everything oh
yeah dregg fruit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well usually one of the top ten
anticipated movies of 2018 has just made
my list after just being the emoji movie
that broke my heart a little bit why the
emoji movies fantastic and this seems
like a great follow up some your what
are you guys doing a wider straight face
animated garbage really is just crushing
my soul right now cuz I love animated
movie so much and that to me just looks
like a whole bunch of nonsense yeah did
not look great I felt like it was the
pitch in the room that's regular
voiceover sounded like this I haven't
heard trailer voiceover like that in a
while yeah you're really laying it out
for me this trailer voiceover like that
and also just the wall of rock guitar
like the whole yeah it's like one big
loud rock sound like who is movie it's
like what are you trying to say to you
maybe you think those might be good I
can't even imagine my little cousin
watching the trailer being like all like
mom dad to see that I want the duck duck
goose toys that's so wrong it really
feels like somebody said hey what's a
well-known to anything
the phrase duck duck goose that game is
a well-known concept cool
can we can we extrapolate under story no
but we can make it the title of this
other movie we have lying around you
guys are cousins going to be so sad when
this film gets a 98 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes if this had a DreamWorks
Animation logo on it I would believe
this is the people that had Shrek I
would have kind of preferred a movie
that was about the game depth but of
course is about over this excellent yeah
you could admit like I like a
competition movie I was like you know a
goose that wants to get in the game
would likely oh yeah I can make it about
inclusivity just made it about little
kids anime kids made it like a really
intense like when Stallone did staying
alive him like to have a doctor group or
you could have made it an r-rated horror
movie about a game duck-duck-goose that
gets deadly as
these are wins all these ideas are just
as good at this movie foodies what about
duck-duck-goose
I mean this almost very generic the
crude jokes look horrible all the jokes
look horrible some of the animation look
dark this is a definition of studio
pitch I feel like that means misfit who
doesn't fit in it yeah yes help somebody
find their way Hall it's two-in-one I
really I really feel the producer or
screenwriter of the room going all right
let me pitch it for you and then the guy
on the other eye going I see in the
trailer god I cracked it and I got to
tell you this might just be a prudish
thing for me but especially in a movie
like this is clearly accessible to
children families it really rubs me the
wrong way when people replace obvious
swear words for like cute puns yeah
right guess look I'm like no I know what
you mean oh I know what you mean I also
really can't stand when animated movies
and animated movie promo material in
particular highlight things that make me
feel like they're talking down to their
audience it's like kid kids are smarter
than theirs are smarter than the emoji
movie and they're smarter than that guys
are you excited to see duck-duck-goose
we are calm yeah catch up and your
wallet and dish out some money or is it
my own be a waste of your plucking time
I'm almost as bad as coming up with puns
as I am at doing accents okay now you
gotta given money in an accent shut the
caca you know you're doing walk you I
can't think of any drive to the real
rejects let's click that notification
Bell John is dead John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram am but don't care
about our ducting channel go to Perry's
channel the Perry never off show
searches so hotel call the Canadian I'm
sorry and irregular very never I'll go
to her channel P number off on Twitter
and Instagram I remember I remember I
spoke your stuff I look at all your
photos of Dewey
oh it's fine that's what they're there
for yeah they're there to be adored
we'll be able to ARDS $100 in cash I
know that's what I should be working on
so hard right now not creating my own
YouTube channel Chloe seriously the only
comments
that again that are super super positive
are when is when GUI appears in one my
videos god forbid he doesn't everyone's
like no that make you resent do it no
because he's beautiful and I walked in
and cut